well whatever else you want to say about
the left they're not like the right they
don't sit around and talk about stuff
forever they just do it right or wrong
usually wrong but they move quick
last year the left targeted the nation's
remaining Confederate statues for
demolition was no vote on this anywhere
ever sometimes it is destroyed the
statues with mob violence they got away
with it of course now they've picked a
new target any statue that offends
anybody in power in Arcada california in
the northern part of the state a statue
of President William McKinley is going
to be torn down on the grounds that he
pursued policies hopeful to Native
Americans of course he did Saturday Bram
Lincoln so of course we await Lincoln's
monuments and dynamiting not really but
you never know Papa Chino is on the
Arcata City Council he voted for the
removal of McKinley statue he joins us
tonight Paul thanks for coming on yeah
you're welcome
so you know I'm not for tearing statues
down without a vote but of all the
people who's tattooed statue you could
tear down Y McKinley it's the only one
we got okay good answer but I mean here
you have a guy who joined the Union Army
at 18 to fight the Confederacy spent you
know years in battle I don't think he is
a rapid reputation as a particularly
cruel guy he himself was a victim of gun
violence says you know why are you
picking on him well I think if you look
at all the stuff about him see you just
mentioned a couple of things but there's
tons of other stuff about this guy and
when when you take the totality of
everything he was responsible for and
what happened during his presidency you
look at it you go okay positive negative
if today I was offered that statue as a
City Councilman I'd say no thank you
so basically I'm correcting one hundred
and twelve year old error of judgment
well I don't know if that's your place
I mean you didn't put the statue there
are you having a town wide vote on this
here's what's happening the City Council
112 or years or so ago decided to put it
there and the City Council has the power
to
remove it if indeed the citizens don't
want that to happen we have referendum
an initiative here in California that
happens constantly and so it can be
simply a thousand signatures and beyond
the ballot well why don't you just let
them vote anyway I mean you don't have
to wait for them to do that but but hold
on I just wonder how you would feel
let's say there's a Paul Patino statue I
hope obviously there never is but let's
say there was how would you like to be
assessed on every bad thing you did I'm
sure you've done good things I'm
positive you've done some pretty bad
things I can just tell how would you
like it if people said we got to tear
this statue down he was flawed I mean
shouldn't we be a little more forgiving
than that of people let me say this I
don't think any human being deserves the
statue we're all equals I think it's a
mistake to put statues up for humans you
know Statue of Liberty it works because
that's not a human okay it's a replica
or a stylized person when you put up a
human you're always gonna have a problem
no matter what human whether it's
Mussolini or whoever it's the problem I
have to say I wasn't expecting you to
say that you're kind of winning me over
a little bit with that argument because
I think that's actually true and we
shouldn't be worshipping politicians
even the good ones are not that good so
I kind of agree I didn't and I'm sure we
don't agree on anything other than that
but I don't think that's a dumb point at
all kind of an Islamic point but still a
pretty good point but since his his
statues up there and no one living made
the decision to put it there you have to
make an affirmative decision to take it
down and by doing that aren't you really
saying you know his sins outweigh the
good things that he did I mean was a
good president he fought against slavery
I mean can we ask even more and by the
way as I said he was a victim of gun
violence shouldn't give you a pass you
know I I totally see the good points and
I see the bad points and I as a as a
elected official a representative of
people in the town I have to say go deep
inside and look at what would I do
I was faced with this any other time and
and 13 years ago it came before us
before and we didn't have a majority so
it stayed this time 13 years later came
up again and we had a majority and so
our majority voted for it to leave have
you guys solved all the problems in your
town other than this is it like
literally a utopia hey look you know
nobody solves all the problems no but I
mean you have like no crimes and nobody
has ever double parked and no one's ever
gotten divorced and like do you know
what I mean nobody chews microwave
burritos over Brussels sprouts like
you've got it all figured out so like in
your spare time you're gonna tear down a
McKinley statue is that pretty much
what's going on no that's that's an
opinion let me put it this way you know
as a city councilman I have to cover
everything this is just one item I don't
like wasting a lot of time on it it's
come to us before it came before I even
lived here this issue and it's like okay
let's stop wasting time on it I'm
willing to take the freight I'll make
the decision to make that motion to move
that thing so that we can be done with
it and move on and not waste any more
time all right so yeah I don't I I
really don't like wasting time about it
okay well I disagree with you but I do
think you make a good point about not
worshiping people I'm with you on that
councilman thank you you're welcome
thanks for having me Jason Nichols his
professor at the University of Maryland
and he joins us tonight professor thanks
a lot for coming on make the cut I mean
unless you agree with the professor I
just talked to who I actually do think
makes a really good point
we shouldn't be naming things after
people especially living politicians
whether it's Kennedy you know killed a
woman or Robert Byrd the Klan recruiter
or any of these politicians should not
be allowed to name things after
themselves I strongly agree with that
but like McKinley really why is he so
sinful well I think you know if we look
at his history he did some things in
terms of what he did with the indigenous
people taking their land giving it to
white settlers breaking up
their their autonomy so I think he has
some some issues in his past but at the
same time I think it's important for us
and it's interesting this discussion
because I think I'm gonna play the
Republican here and say that you had a
City Council a local group who has made
a decision for their community that's
what they're elected to do and yet we
you and I here in our in our shirts and
ties here in Washington are gonna sit
here and tell them that what they did
was was wrong I feel totally empowered
to pass judgment on the decisions that
governments make okay you have no you
have no I mean I I'm allowed to have a
view on that and I do absolutely and
just because the government is small
doesn't mean it doesn't make terrible
decisions
I'm not that kind of conservative who
thinks that you know small guy I mean
there's a lot of tyranny that takes
place on City Council's I've certainly
seen it having lived in a small town but
here I guess is the point I'm making
we're retro actively judging people
selectively so you wouldn't have any
problem with a monument to the Cherokees
and the Trail of Tears I would assume
because they're an oppressed people but
of course they brought their slaves with
them they're African American slaves not
attacking the Cherokees I'm merely
pointing out that like history is a lot
more complicated than we pretend it is
and you know that of course as a
professor so why are we now pretending
that everything is in stark black and
white and they're good people and
they're bad people and nobody in between
that's a lie
I think you know the primary thing we're
talking about presidents and what
they've done is that we need to have a
dialogue about the totality of what
they've done I'm just saying in this
particular case and the most important
point to me is that activists say that
they are going to raise the $65,000 that
it takes to remove the statue so it's
not even going to be a burden upon the
taxpayers and it's gonna be housed
somewhere they have a veteran it's just
your classic kind of red guard nonsense
where we destroy the past thinking that
that's going to create how does the
future it is your task still exist and
they said they're gonna move it in doors
just like I said with with Confederates
that
like nobody is actually offended by this
that's not there's a job by William
McKinley there's a Native American
community 20 miles south of Arcada
who said that they don't like seeing
this statue okay we're gonna talk to one
of them tomorrow and look I try to
respect people's opinions sir but taking
down the statue will not improve the
life of a single person in that
community as you know but let me ask you
this as long as that we're using these
criteria why do we have an FDR memorial
here in Washington after he literally
put in internment camps people on the
basis of their skin color why don't we
what do we have of that I mean I like I
think the living memory by the way I
mean some of the people were in those
camps are still alive it's this wasn't
300 years ago it was like 80 years ago
yeah no I mean I think you're you're
trying to make an argument that I'm not
making you know or you're trying to sit
here and debate what I'm saying here is
you know just like you know people may
be offended by certain things in certain
communities I don't think we should
necessarily force it upon that community
to have that statue if they want to
remove it this isn't it on our kata and
I and I also think that the marijuana
use levels so high in that town that I'm
not sure that they'll ever kind of like
get it together a statue that I'm
betting on that do you think there's a
principle here that's worth talking
about and that is how do we assess
figures out of our past do we impose the
values of the present moment the
transitory values that we have this
right the moment on people retro
actively or do we take a broader view
and say a lot of people who are heroic
Cesar Chavez for example flawed guy beat
up illegal aliens I don't know I think
he was a net positive to the state of
California and is his labor organizing
he should I'm saying what I'm going to
distort history for political reasons
well here's here's what I believe why
can't we take this McKinley statue and
put it somewhere where we can have a
dialogue about what he represented in
you know both the good and the bad that
would be us anything about the camera
yes you know I've been living in a
museum that's where they can because
nobody actually cares about learning
about history and I bet you a thousand
that's a problem and I don't it's a huge
problem I bet you can't find 15 people
in America who can tell me 10 things
William McKinley did I honestly think
that's true I believe including the
people or I think that there's one
Arcadia can tell you ten things that and
I don't believe that for a second I
really don't we're gonna talk to what I
think tomorrow and I'm gonna say just
I'm gonna sit here in silence is you
tell me facts about William McKinley and
I bet you that'll be the shortest
conversation ever aired on television
we'll see professor thank you thank you
you're that new trucker